Some traits can be obvious and distinguish easily
in whether they are learned or innate
To help us illustrate this concept a little bit better. We have
asked some udacious friends to come in today and talk
to us for a bit. This is Clifton and
Eduardo and I am pretty sure both these guys have
the innate ability to speak, don't you guys?
>> Yeah off course.
>> I am pretty sure these words are coming from my mouth.
>> Okay, great, and based on their answers I would also
assume they would understand me if I were to speak in
english. And say science is amazing, because they both learned how
to speak English, but Clifton here also knows how to speak Mandarin.
>>
[mandarin]
>> And, what does that mean, exactly?
>> Oh, it just means, Science is amazing, in Mandarin.
>> Clifton can do that because he learned to speak both
Mandarin and English. But, he may not understand Spanish, let's say.
>>
[spanish]
What?
>> Exactly.
>> That just means science is amazing in Spanish.
>> Okay, now I want you guys, see
if you can have a conversation with each other.
>>
[FOREIGN]
>> okay guys. How's it going? Are you able to understand each other?
>> Not really. That's because you both have the
innate ability to speak, but you've learned different languages.
>> Another good example of a learned trait is something
like religious belief or cultural practice. Usually, people believe in a
religion that they were raised in, but later in life, they
can adopt a different religion, or even no religion at all.
>> Another example would be music. You can perceive music and
then you can have music that you like. Which one do you think is more
of a learned trait and which one do you think is more of an innate trait?